foreign
that's incredible
die from Washington DC
yes that's me in can I tell you
something hilarious
um in college I had a roommate from a
Tiny Town in Kansas that was amazing
he's one of my best friends in the world
still
but he listened to like Tony Toni Toni
and he had like in sync Christmas record
I did not I had lots of Pantera records
so Pantera was coming to town and I'd
seen them a few times and I was like we
got to go to the show
and so he went to the mirror and he
wrote die on his forehead
but it was in the mirror so it came out
backwards
oh no and then it was like in permanent
marker and so he had died right on his
head backwards for the whole show oh
gosh and it was awesome and now in any
time I hear the word die it makes me
think of that except that's your name
incredible all right die from Washington
what's up
hey so I am a homeschooling mom of four
kids and I'm actually calling about my
number three today he's nine years old
and he is probably the cutest little guy
you'll ever meet
um he's really funny he's very
light-hearted just a kind kind boy
um but
um he's also super super competitive
like takes it so much to heart and I
mean in everything it's not just
athletically it's in board games it's in
pickup Sports it's
um he plays baseball so if they lose a
game it's borderline devastating for him
but the other thing that he is really
competitive and sensitive about is
school and since I'm his teacher
I get the brunt of it and I actually get
to see his reaction to feelings of
failure or losing and so what he does
when he feels frustrated or like he's
just not getting a concept is he will
just turn into this tiny ball of rage
and what that ends up looking like is he
has very negative self-talk he'll go up
to his room and he will scream and at
the top of his lungs he'll yell you know
I'm so stupid I'll never be good at
anything why doesn't anybody like me I'm
so lonely you know things like that just
really devolved into everything that
feels like it's wrong in his life and
depending on how upset he is like what
he's upset about and this is the part
that I'm actually really concerned about
is he will get his nails into his arms
or his his legs until he's either got
really deep bruisy like marks or he's
bleeding
um but like I said outside of school and
sports like things that involve
competition or where he can get
frustrated he's just really he's just
really a good boy and I don't really
know how to manage this because my
husband and I were really intentional
with the kids like finding things to
praise about them shaming and guilting
over Sports school performance that's
just that's not part of who we are or
what we do so I'm really looking like to
understand and then move forward in
helping him deal with these issues in
the more healthy way that's a great
question
um I'm going to tell you out of the gate
that I recommend that you take him to a
local play therapist there in Washington
okay okay and um
off the top of my head here's what it
sounds like how old are your kids
I have a 15 year old 13 year old
nine-year-old and six-year-old okay
so that's quite the Gap
um yeah
I'm gonna rattle off a few things that
it that are just coming to mind okay
um
so we're talking about a kid who is
somewhat disregulated and excessively so
for a nine-year-old okay
um
either
well
that could be a kid who has is quietly
being bullied or abused by an older
sibling or an older sibling's friends
okay
um that is experienced a few things
basically he's got an engine inside of
him that is too big for his little body
to process
okay and normally that engine slowly
opens up over time it happens through
hormones it happens to puberty it
happens through life experiences we call
that wisdom right and that and the the
dream of a parent is that we can walk
alongside our kids in these Milestone
markers as this thing this engine slowly
grows and opens up
if there's sexual abuse at a young age
boom that you have an adult engine
inside of a child body now if there is
bullying that goes on that that
accelerates the opening of the growth of
this engine inside of this little body
and the body it's just like putting a
Ferrari engine inside of a of a of a of
a Prius it the the car can't handle the
the what's under the hood right and so
sometimes it is external behaviors that
have happened to this kid and that's
where that's where a
um number one I want you to your
immediate thought is that's not
happening here that should be your
immediate thought as a good parent okay
yeah yeah and the second thought should
be
something's happening
and I'm gonna go get it checked out okay
do you think that so due to the nature
of my husband's employment we do move
fairly frequently and when I say move
we're moving from state to state do you
think that could be a reason why this
big dysregulation is happening
I mean it could be
okay it could be
um
I think
so I could go to the store right now I
have an old I have an old pickup truck I
could go to the store and get six or
seven different types of shocks on my
truck I could get performance shocks
that made I could go over rocks I could
get um like Cruiser shocks that made it
real smooth to drive down the road I
could get jacked up like you know make
my car talk but all those shocks have
different levels of sensitivity to them
our kids are very much the same that's
how you considered a kitchen table and
you tell one joke and three of your kids
start dying laughing and one just goes
into a frenzy and starts like why are
you making fun of me like whoa they they
naturally have a a different level of
sensitivity all four of those shocks
work great they're just they're just
different and so we often try to create
like we have we have kids with different
level sensitivity and you've got that
and that's okay
um in fact that's beautiful and we want
to honor that it just looks different
different context and some things that
may
Empower I've got one kid that if we we
did we moved a lot it made him very
resilient my other kid it would have
been a much bigger challenge
just because there was a sensitivity
there could be that could be that
um it could just like I mentioned could
be a sensitivity the other thing could
be this when you have four kids there is
somewhat of a Hunger Games for identity
who am I right yes yeah do you see me
hey Mom do you see me do You See Me Do
you see me and this is the the benefit
and the curse of homeschooling is there
is no other adult that can give your kid
praise you have to be the person
yeah and accidentally not accidentally
it's very naturally
our children gravitate they find a path
towards here's how I'm seen
and sometimes when we catch our kids
being good which you said you and your
husband do which is awesome we all
parents need to spend more time catching
their kids doing great things instead of
pointing out the things that they're
failing at
yeah but
sometimes little younger kids will watch
the praise that older siblings get for
achievement and performance
okay and they will fall into a path of
that's how I get Mom and Dad to love me
and then they're not as good as brother
or sister they're not as fast or as
smart as brother and sister and in their
little Minds The Path towards
connectivity with Mom and Dad has been
blocked because I suck
yeah you see it actually that's exactly
what what I see okay yeah I can totally
see that that resonates a lot with us
because my oldest started college when
she was 12 and is a performance pianist
my next oldest is a p or not a pianista
performance guitarist and so they have
these things that they've excelled
incredibly at and he hasn't quite found
it and then Here Comes Daryl and Daryl
loves trucks
right and here's here's the challenge as
a parent Daryl's still awesome
yes and if it wasn't for the Daryl's in
the world princess piano players
couldn't get themselves to and from
practice
that's right right and so the challenge
that you have as a parent is
some very specific one-on-one time
this is a great opportunity for like the
weekly breakfast in the morning that you
do not have time for I understand
yeah but that your kid desperately needs
yes and it may be that once a week mom
and
little Daryl go out for breakfast and
the 15 year old has an opportunity to
teach one of the morning lessons
and we're going to be our dad stays at
home on those mornings but what we're
going to start doing is being very
intentional about relationship because
we want to over time this is not going
to happen overnight is it going to be
like a one two five year Journey you're
on now
we want this
we want this kid to realize that there
is no obstruction to any path I take
towards love to Mom
yeah right and yeah
um yeah so and so plays a piano great
my I'll give my dad and mom super props
on this I was a big
um super 5A High School football guy in
in uh in Texas right that's a religion
right my dad wore my letter jacket
around that was a whole thing there was
like seven or eight thousand people that
showed up every Friday to my games it
was a it was a Mayhem my brother
went to college on a cello scholarship
and
he was a virtuoso he was incredible
but it was V it was a d i i remember
going to college as my brother was
entering High School thinking I don't
know how my dad's going to toggle this
and he did it masterfully because he
never my brother always
he went to all the concerts he cheered
for him he talked to him about the
performance he made sure he was
practicing he went to my brother's like
rock band shows so it was a my it my dad
and my both my dad and my mom did a
masterful job of never making anybody
feel less than does that make sense and
that just is your goal and man it's
awesome when you can go to church and
talk about well Susie's just won another
national competition playing the piano
and Little Billy is also good
and Daryl loves trucks right it's it
doesn't sound doesn't have a quite ring
to it that's your job as Mom and Dad
yeah
but all I have to say is I would
um I would set up an appointment with a
play of therapies nine I think that
would be a really valuable exercise just
to get an outside perspective and to
rule out
to some things happen behind closed
doors that we didn't know about
is there some bullying going on is there
some abusive Tendencies going on is
there some overly type a older brother
and sister that this nine-year-old is
internalizing as less than like whatever
a great therapist can help ferret some
of that out and it may just be your
nine-year-old sees the older ones and
says oh that's how to get Mom and Dad to
love me
and in a busy house with four little
kids and you're running around and
homeschooling it's real easy to
say way to go you did a great job on
that exam you did a great job on this
thing
and suddenly the kids adopt achievement
as the way to Mom and Dad's heart and
then as parents it's our job to let them
know on a regular basis not just with
words but demonstrating it
I'll Always Love You
regardless of what you do regardless of
where you go you've always got a place
here both in my home and in my heart
because you're my kid
that's a tough mission for every parent
but that's what we signed up for die
thank you so much for your call thank
you Robin
easily the best name of anyone who's
ever called into this show
um and thank you for caring about all of
your kids all of them